alors voilà pour ce qui est des enfants
de justin trudeau et de sophie grégoire
emmanuel bonsoir à vous bonsoir rebond
soir emmanuel on va pour boucler la
boucle
si vous le voulez bien essayé
d'entrevoir à quoi pourra ressembler ce
premier conseil des ministres et
première question que je vous pose
le ministre des finances on en parlait
avec gerald tout à l'heure de gros défis
de ce côté là le gros défi c'est sûr est
surtout patrice l'embarras du choix
il ya un an par ailleurs qui ressort du
lot si on regarde les candidats
principaux le petit se présenteraient
monsieur trudeau pourrait entre autres
nommés score bryson qui a été élu en
nouvelle écosse qui faisait partie de
son conseil économique bien sûr ravi
coderre qui a été miné ses finances sous
paul martin qui vient de la saskatchewan
et le nom qui sort du lot c'est vraiment
belle mort non c'est comme si le pdg de
la grande firme de ressources humaines -
au chat perle à toronto a été recruté
dans l'espoir d'en faire un éventuel
ministre des finances déjà lors du
congrès du parti libéral en 2014
lorsqu'il avait donné une conférence à
ce congrès là on le décrivait comme le
futur ministre des finances de justin
trudeau
donc oui monsieur trudeau a l'embarras
du choix mais c'est vraiment lui en ce
moment qui ressort du lot comme étant le
favori c'est réellement nous c'est très
bien c'est noté merci manuel et puis au
québec avec le fort contingent de
députés libéraux du québec il a
l'embarras du choix
oui et le premier surtout que la force
du québec dans la représentation un
libéral aux communes sera ré refléter
dans ce cabinet l'embarras du choix pour
monsieur trudeau c'est de pouvoir oui
choisir des ministres à montréal mais à
l'extérieur de montréal
si on regarde l'ensemble de la boucle et
nom qui sort du lot à montréal c'est
principalement bien sûr sa recrue
vedette dans un de ces quartiers villes
mélanie joly
marc garneau parlementaire qui avait été
lui lui sous paul martin à un dj os
montes pablo rodriguez qui a été à ses
côtés depuis les débuts de la course à
la direction de justin trudeau qui avait
perdu en 2011 et qui vient d'être réélu
l'est de l'île et bien sûr stéphane dion
qui est un parlementaire de grande
expérience et qui est parmi ceux au
parti libéral condé cyber court juste à
cause de son expérience de ministre de
l'environnement comme potentiellement
quelqu'un qui pourrait qui sait
retourner à l'environnement encore que
monsieur trudeau a là aussi beaucoup
l'embarras du choix non plusieurs
députés qui ont une expertise sur ce
front là le s'il veut pas refaire un
cabinet du passé n'ont plus que semaine
de paris à quelques semaines de paris
monsieur dion serait celui qui qui
serait le plus près d'une certaine façon
parce qu'il a toutes les clés de ce
dossier là en tête la wii il a toutes
les clés de ce dossier là en tête mais
monsieur trudeau ne fait pas un conseil
des ministres pour les prochains trois
mois mais pour vraiment donné le ton la
couleur la saveur de ce nouveau
gouvernement qu'il veut présenter aux
canadiens donc est-ce que c'est lui qui
retiendront pas de façon voilée réponse
bien wc revenir le 4 novembre
mais je vous disais un peu plus tôt donc
monsieur trudeau a le choix aussi à
l'extérieur de montréal
nos deux noms qui viennent en tête dans
la région de québec
on avait beaucoup pas être la
circonscription de louis hébert mais la
vedette elle était dans le comté d'à
côté québec une victoire semblait est
possible et lui hier jean-yves duclos
économiste de l'université laval très
reconnu qu'ils feraient certainement
partie d'un conseil des ministres
trudeau avec un portfolio à saveur
économique
françois philippe champagne qui lui a
réussi à se faire élire dans l'ancienne
circonscription de monsieur chrétien un
avocat qu une vaste expérience
internationale qui est assez connu aussi
au sein du parti libéral certainement un
des noms qui sont sur leur radar au
québec pour monsieur trudeau survol
rapide en ontario en ontario là aussi il
ya l'embarras du choix pour le bénéfice
de nos auditeurs j'essaie d'éviter les
noms que tout le monde connaît des
jeunes comme david mcguinty ecce terra
je vous dirais qu'il ya bill blair dans
la région de toronto qui l ancien chef
de police de toronto
christoph links et une amie de justin
trudeau une journaliste chroniqueuse
économique beaucoup écrit sur les
inégalités
ensuite dans la société qui a été réélu
jing philpot peu connu mais qui est une
médecin reconnu qui a dirigé services
d'un hôpital et les sur la liste
cesserait lumineuse de la santé
quatre films et cana avocate qui a causé
la surprise dans le tableau à 100 par
défaisant le néo-démocrate paul dewar
elle aussi une avocate qu'une vaste
expérience à l'international en termes
de droits de la personne j'ai oublié le
nom sur ma liste c'est bien sûr un giuly
qui ont été élus en banlieue d'ottawa
tout juste à l'extérieur ancien chef
d'état major de l'armée de terre à la
défense aux affaires étrangères mais on
va voir
il a vraiment et on s'en aperçoit quand
on fait l'exercice il l'a vraiment
l'embarras du choix et tout à l'heure
lors de sa première conférence de presse
ce trou douadi ce dont je suis le plus
fier c'est qu'on a des on a eu des
victoires en plus partout au canada
donc dans l'ouest ils pu aller chercher
des gens mais ce trou d'eau à la
possibilité de vraiment avoir un conseil
des ministres qui représente l'ensemble
du pays chaque province
du côté de l'ouest du pays on peut
regarder par exemple
jim kerr qui a été élu au manitoba à
winnipeg qui lui est l'ancien président
fondateur du conseil des affaires du
manitoba au manitoba business canso
quant à ses députés en alberta qui a été
lu donc qui a causé la surprise qu'ils
étaient venus dans cadbury sauce centre
et jodie sweetin rebels qui elle est une
procureure de la couronne une ancienne
chef les premières nations pour la
colombie britannique
une femme d'une grande crédibilité là
bas qui elle aussi est aux côtés de
justin trudeau depuis un bon bout tant
elle était à ce fameux congrès de
montréal en deux à 2014 où déjà on
présentait les vedettes d'un éventuel
concert il expliqué ces gens là qui ont
réussi à se faire élire hier et on on a
le temps nous pressons n'a pas oublié
l'atlantique
il y en aura mis il ya des amis de
monsieur trudeau et tu le blague
oui dominique leblanc qui lui a été élu
on a trait aussi bien sûr
potentiellement seamus o'regan à terre
neuve
judy foote qui elle est et whip du parti
mais qui a une grande expérience aussi
que ministre provincial donc vraiment
qu'on regarde la cohorte libéral cette
fois ci monsieur trudeau a l'embarras du
choix le défi aussi de respecter sa
promesse d'avoir la parité hommes femmes
dans ce conseil des ministres qui les
sept îles pressentir au début serait
plus petit que 40 on va voir comment
évolue et je voyais arriver la parité
homme femme parce que jean charest avait
fait au québec il l'a reproduit
aujourd'hui en conférence de presse en
disant oui c'est une c'est un engagement
y aura autant de femmes que d'hommes
renseignements et c'est dans son ou sa
plateforme électorale ils y tiennent
donc on verra la couleur de tout ça dans
deux semaines et 1 jour
emmanuel merci pour cette campagne merci
pour votre collaboration quotidienne
merci pour cette belle soirée électorale
hier claire au résultat vous avez été
impeccable merci beaucoup plus très
bientôt ça continue prochain gros rendez
vous pour nous certainement c'est le 4
novembre à cannes avant de recevoir
lille je le sens pas mal ça aussi
toujours un plaisir d'être à vos côtés
patrice salut